i'm in half now guys
i'm gonna try and get up to the to the
top four
see if my sister's up there
here we go see my sister i'm going
upstairs let's check our bedroom
hey what's up
oh you can open it just like the game
is it blood the hair dye's gone there's
usually hair dye in this bathroom
secret passage yeah take a passage
were there hostages and gone
of home
yes
the twist was the house was actually
going to animal bay
hell yeah i can go upstairs
i got into the secret passageway where
all that ouija board yeah
there's a characteristic in my left i
killed him
just like gone home
did you go into the ouija board
yeah ouija board rooms there
even got the ouija board room in here
check it out
we've come home to gone home
we've gotta come home for christmas and
this is
okay let's watch tv turn something on
to get home
maybe you can't go out front
yeah they won't let you do that
oh really you start like inside
so we do like grenade tips and routes
and stuff for this map
you